cent jours après avoir pris le pouvoir
les libéraux même les vétérans sont
toujours aussi émerveillé seconde a
gagné l'élection quand on voit toute
évidence avait tendance à toujours porté
donc par l'enthousiasmé de leur entrée
en scène des plus beaux souvenirs
depuis vous est terminée c'est quoi
c'est quand j'ai été assermenté comme
député parlez-en à mélanie joly propulsé
ministre du patrimoine
si encore là cette magie lot et j'espère
manu est ce avec le longtemps j'espère
vraiment que ça va être le longtemps on
fait si je pensais justement le plus
grand legs de nos 100 premiers jours
c'est le temps qu'on a donné c'est le
fait qu'on n'est pas déconnecté de la
population
les voix ensoleillée de justin trudeau
veulent dépasser les sourires les selphy
c'est tout style de gouvernement qui
veut imposer ou proximité avec la
population
un optimisme qu'il affiche à l'étranger
de manier à davos et qui se reflète du
temps autour de la table du conseil des
ministres il ya comme un esprit d'équipé
l'esprit d'amitié en entraide convoi au
caucus et au cabinet qui commence
directement du patron le pouvoir ici ne
s'arrête pas à la porte du bureau de
justin trudeau
il s'exerce au conseil des ministres
femmes autochtones évaluation des
pipelines accueil des réfugiés au
gouvernement trudeau les ministres
doivent travailler en équipe
chaque grande initiative implique une
multitude de ministère chaque question
est étudiée sous tous ses angles
je me retrouve à être impliqué dans l'os
et d'infrastructures de d'immigration et
d'affaires étrangères et ses seins parce
que ça permet d'avoir un point de vue
qui est assez globale sur d'édition
comprend qui permet qu'on n'est pas
seulement un an vasco
à ce rythme les décisions ne viennent
pas toujours vite en 100 jours
les libéraux ont agi dans le dossier des
baisses d'impôts pour la classe moyenne
de l'accueil des réfugiés serieys
processus de sélection dessinateur ils
ont finalement annoncé les termes de la
nouvelle mission contre le groupe armé
état islamique
mais pour le reste on consulte on
consulte les familles autochtones au
sujet de l'éventuelle enquête sur les
femmes disparues et assassinées
on consulte les v les provinces pour les
infrastructures
on consulte pour la légalisation de la
marijuana et pour les changements
climatiques
nous avons quatre ans devant nous alors
on va quand même arrivé à un moment
important une centaine de jours mais il
nous reste quand même 900 autres jours
devant nous la pourquoi pas s'inspirer
de ce qui se fait de mieux et de
personnes qui ont peut-être encore plus
réfléchie que nous à cette expertise
leur écoute et on n'a pas toutes les
solutions on n'a pas toutes les réponses
mais on sait qu'on a accès à beaucoup
d'informations qui nous permettra à
terme de prendre les bonnes décisions
mais une telle approche n'est pas sans
risques le risque de voir si
consultation rimer avec paralysie lui
leader parlementaire le reconnaît
comment on peut d'une façon s'occuper du
quotidien des problèmes que
nécessairement un gouvernement doit
gérer semaine après semaine
mais pas perdre le focus sur les
engagements importants majeur que
nous sommes donnés et le quotidien
rattrape vite des députés tahoua il a
fallu que quelques semaines pour que le
spectacle de la période des questions
deviennent par moments d'isolant moi je
pense qu'il faut constater que le climat
le débat politique a est beaucoup moins
personnalisée beaucoup moins peut-être
vicieux que c'était il ya un an on peut
encore faire des efforts pour
l'améliorer le parlement si la lune de
miel dure toujours
mélanie joly et six collègues savent
bien qu'il ne sera pas éternelle
c'est sûr qu'on faire des erreurs c'est
sûr qu'on va faire mais si aussi d'avoir
cette immunité la hat encore vraiment
les les avoués
puis j'espère aussi ça appartenait
besoin de mes amis à shediac 1 soit il
ya quelques semaines qui m'a dit j'ai
l'impression que après élection vous
étiez au gouvernement mais de plus en
plus vous avez l'air des gens qui sont
au pouvoir et je pense qu'il voulait
dire qu'on il faut assumer nos décisions
maintenant il faut prendre des décisions
et compris les décisions qui vont être
difficiles
elles viendront est elle assez vite dans
le budget d'ici quelques semaines
je jure solennellement sincèrement que
j'agirai en fidèle et loyal servi